- My next guest is one of
the hottest WWE superstars
on the planet.
In January, she made history
as the second black person
to win the Royal Rumble.
Who was the first you may ask?
Well, just a little known
wrestler by the name of The Rock,
not bad footsteps to follow in.
That's why we call her
a whole lotta woman.
(upbeat music)
All right, she's known
as the EST of the WWE.
Please, welcome WWE
Superstar, Bianca Belair.
(upbeat music)
Woo, first of all-
- Hi.
- Wait, I love the room you're in
with the black and gold,
that's so Gatsby, I love it.
That's super cool.
- Thank you.
- [Kerry] Yes.
- Well, and also, I have to ask you,
what does the EST of the WWE?
What does that mean?
What does that stand for?
- I call myself the EST of WWE.
It basically means that I'm the strongest,
I'm the fastest, I'm the roughest,
I'm the toughest, I'm the quickest,
I'm the greatest, I'm the best.
The B-E-S-T is anything
good that ends in E-S-T.
Now I've played sports
my whole entire life.
And I was a collegiate hurdler
at the University of Tennessee.
And afterwards, I went into CrossFit
and I made my own gear
and I really stood out.
So I was contacted by Mark
Henry, who is a Hall of Famer.
And he asked me if I ever
thought of being a WWE wrestler.
And he told me just be myself.
I went through two tryouts and
I got hired in April of 2016.
- Oh my gosh, just like listening to you.
(audience clapping)
We're so much alike (laughs)
So so similar.
You're so athletic, good Lord.
So you're known for your long braid,
which is fabulous by the way,
we even have video of
you jump roping with it.
So do you use it in the ring?
It's amazing.
- Oh yes, I definitely use it.
At first, it was just a signature look
so that I could stand out and be unique.
And I had a match where I
threw it at one of the girls
and it made this huge noise
and the crowd reacted.
And I was like, what was that?
Was that my hair?
And that's when I realized,
oh, this is not just a signature look,
this can be used as a weapon.
So, I definitely use this as
my secret weapon in the ring.
- I already see the movie
and you're like some kind of really cool,
I don't know,
you're saving the day and
you're using your hair
and you're just kicking ass with it.
I don't know, I see it.
I'm just saying, are your
parents your biggest fans
or did they get worried
with just all of that?
- Oh, my parents have been
there every step of the way.
They always support me even with track
and gymnastics and CrossFit,
anything that I do, they support me.
So when it came to being in the WWE,
they have completely fallen in love.
My dad gets very crazy.
He gets excited.
He falls over the back of the couch
because he gets so excited
every time I come out,
even if it's my entrance
and nobody ever believes me,
but my mom gets amped up.
They're my biggest fans.
And I just love them so much.
And it's amazing to
have parents like them.
I'm just super blessed.
- Well, we actually have
video of Bianca's parents
watching her from home, so take a look.
(air whooshing)
(cheering excitedly)
- [Bianca's Dad] Yeah, baby, woo!
- [Bianca's Mom] Oh,
wow, point to the sun,
point to the sun.
(laughing)
- I would watch that show.
Oh my gosh, it's amazing.
They are amped.
It's like they're there with you.
- Yes, it gives me, I get
so excited watching them
and I love that they can
be a part of this with me.
I'm tearing up now just watching it,
but they are the best parents
that I could ever ask for.
- That really is a beautiful thing.
Well, Wrestle Mania is this weekend.
So, what makes this year
so significant, you think?
- Well, for me,
this will be my first
Wrestle Mania title match,
and I'm actually going
up against Sasha Banks
who is the Smack Down Women's Champion.
And we are actually creating
history on this night.
It'll be the first time that
two African-American women
are having a title match at Wrestle Mania.
So we're gonna be in the greatest thing
of all creating history.
(audience clapping)
It's also gonna be two nights.
It'll be on April 10th and April 11th
at Raymond James Stadium in Tampa Bay.
It'll be the first time
that we're having fans back in a year.
We're gonna be on Peacock.
It'll be the first time that
Wrestle Mania be on Peacock.
It's the new home of the WWE Network.
We're gonna have 25,000 fans.
We're following all safety protocols.
We're having pods,
we're social distancing.
They're doing temperature
checks, masks are required.
And we just really been doing
a lot of PSA announcements
about COVID and vaccinations
and everyone's super excited
to get back to normal.
And I think the first step
is everyone rolling up their
sleeves, doing their part,
getting vaccinated so that
we can get back to normal.
And I think we're jump-starting
that with having a two night
Wrestle Mania with 25,000 fans.
It's gonna feel like a family reunion
in having our fans back and
being able to create history
in front of our fans with Sasha Banks.
And I'll be going for the Smack
Down Women's Championship.
And hopefully, I'll be walking out
as the new champion at Wrestle Mania.
- Okay, well, here's the
thing, I need the video
of your parents watching
you win that (laughs)
'cause I feel like what you're gonna do
is gonna be nothing in
comparison to how crazy they get.
They're gonna be so excited, (laughs)
- Probably gonna pass out,
we're gonna need to carry
them out on a stretcher.
- I know, he's already
falling off couches.
Well, you're also, I think
this is really cool too
because when you have this kind of power,
this kind of spotlight,
it's really cool that you
use it for other things,
not just for oneself.
So you're also involved in
a program called Girl Up.
So, can you tell us about it?
- Yes, it's amazing.
WWE and Girl Up, they partner together
to promote gender equity in sports.
And WWE has launched the
Girl Up scholarship fund
where they provide scholarships
for 10 girls around the world.
And it's just super important
to encourage young girls
to get into sports and stay in sports
because it just promotes
so many great qualities.
And I play sports all throughout
my life since I was five.
And I really feel like
it's really contributed
to the success that
I'm experiencing today.
And so, WWE, Girl Up, and
also Sports For Purpose
which is another program that we have,
we just wanna make sure that
we're providing the resources
and the opportunities and the
information to young girls
to encourage them to get into
sports and stay in sports.
And we're providing these
spaces to have conversations.
These must be the conversations
which we do by having
panels with a female coach
which I've been a part of.
And we're just talking
about the importance
of girls getting in
sports and also talking
about the importance of
representation of females in sports.
So it's amazing things that
WWE and Girl Up are doing.
I'm so happy to be a part of it.
- Absolutely, absolutely.